欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
这一章节我们来讲一下关于营销力
如何去分析以及怎么样去提升
它有哪些坑需要我们规避的
我这个截图就是我们后台的营销力的一个截图
这个是定制赛道的
那么针对这些指标
我们前面也说了
你要去理解这些指标代表的是什么东西
以及你要清楚的知道它的统计维度
还有哪些
那么我们来看一下它具体的提升的方法
首先我们来看一下流量指数
其实就是我们所说的访客或者是点击量
加上买家的质量
通过这两个维度
这是第一个维度
这是第二个维度
来评估我们的流量指数的
第二个就是商机指数
商机指数就是通过
巡盘PM订单的量来进行
折算了,就变成了商机指数, 商机转化率就是等于
询盘加TM加订单除以访客乘以100%
这个得到的数据, 那么为什么我这里看到的, 比如说商机转化率, 为什么不等于商机指数除以
营销流量指数呢, 因为这里面还有一个就是买家质量的衡量, 所以说他们
这里的数值是不相等的, 所以这个并不能作为等式去计算, 只能作为大致的一个评估方向, 因为这些都是指数
指数,指数就是折合计算出来的, 并不是真实的数据, 那么提升营销率, 我们要
遵从哪个原则呢?就是差的产品, 我们要果断的舍弃, 让好的产品更好, 因为这里的营销率
是我们上面写的这一段, 包括直通车, 顶展, 问鼎, 访客营销, EDM, RFQ, 这些去推广的产品和营销的产品
才被统计到
这些数据里面的
平时的自然流量是不被统计到这里面的, 它是这里面的产品的流量
才会被包含到这个板块里面的
所以说我们要
用好的产品去获得更多的流量才能够提升他的这些商机转化率还有流量指数这些才是最有效的
那么具体怎么做我们来看一下第一个就是
推优品也就是我们在推广的时候推优品特别是爆品一定要优先推广
同时我们在推广的时候一定要注意商机转化率比如说有很多人在推广的时候
那个产品消耗非常的多但是
一个循环TM都没有
那么这种产品一定要注意因为这个会拉低你的
商机转化率的
所以一定要注意这个盘快
第二个就是每周优化顶奖问题拉升点击率
第三个就是每日做网客营销, EDM, 营销, 报, RFQ, 这些都要去做
因为这里面有每个账号有20条
这里面所有的客群只要你付费了那么你这里会有大量的可以营销的客户
第4个就是上班期间内5分钟内, 万万回应买家, 夜间的话我们要设置智能阶段
因为这里面的话是一个平均回复时间这里要计算的, 所以说我们要做操作这个就是为了体重这个数据, 避坑
不要持续高曝光, 高消耗, 无商机的产品还在推广, 这种情况一定要几时换品, 我刚才说的
换品就是为了
拉升你这个商机转化率, 因为有些产品它高消耗, 也就是它在
持续的高点机
有访客, 也就是访客逐渐的增大, 但是呢这个
没有增大, 这个商机转化率是不是下降
所以说一定要及时的去注意这个商机转化率
如果你遇到这种问题一定要及时换品或者是对整个计划进行一个详细的优化
那么这个就是我们营销率的分析以及它的提升方法
还有要规避的这一个坑
那么如果你店铺里面当前这个板块的数据不是很好
那么你就要开始去调整了
主要从直通车进行切入是最快提升的
那麼這節課我們就先講到這裡